Chris waters here with the GameSpot news
update apparently a five-year-old has
found a security flaw in the Xbox one
allowing him to access his father's
account without using the password the
exploit which has already been fixed was
discovered by a kid in San Diego named
Christopher von hassel after he entered
the wrong password when trying to access
his dad's Xbox Live account cheeky
little bugger by attempting to log in
with an incorrect password users are
taken to a second verification screen
where the child found that by simply
filling up the password field with
spaces he was able to access the account
after besting the multi-billion dollar
company the preschooler said to local
news station KGTV that he was like yeah
it he was like yeah he was like yeah he
was like yeah he was like yeah then he
was like yeah after realizing what he'd
done Kristofferson Christopher did I say
Christopher Christopher that's my name
Christopher said he got nervous that his
dad would find out instead his father
was amazed awesome is that he reported
the flaw to Microsoft who added
Christopher to their list of security
researchers that have helped make
Microsoft online services more secure
they rewarded Christopher with four
games $50 and a year-long subscription
to Xbox Live well guess that goes to
show that all computer hacking has just
randomly entering characters and numbers
until you find a security flaw also I
really understand computers very well
then he was like yeah that he was like
yeah yeah he was like yeah yeah that he
was like yeah that he was like yeah